[Music]
so
on this table terry is drawing up uh
which you can tell
on this table we're doing madonna this
is uh
dr mary simone she's one of our uh
registered
doctor pharmacist that's the one i got
and they're doing great work and then
the president got pfizer and then the
governor got
j j yep all covered so
first one's the best one mary you want
to explain what you're doing a little
bit to the vice president of the
governor
yes so we are drawing up the modern
vaccine and the physical vaccines
preparing
the moderna vaccine and we get 10 doses
out of a vial
0.5 ml and the pfizer vaccine we get
we are driving 0.3 mls for intramuscular
administration
are we getting the extra dose out of
most of the bile stuff we're getting six
doses out of
pfizer and getting 10 doses out of order
that's that's great and what i know is
happening here is the doctor and all of
these
incredible medical health professionals
have a goal of getting
10 000 shots and arms a week that's our
goal right
yes that's incredible that's incredible
thank you all i know it requires a lot
in terms of here
all that you do to care for folks and
and the work that you're doing around
the clock and
you're making such a huge difference so
thank you all thank you thank you thank
you you guys have been working
non-stop like this since january and
they're just getting tired
you guys are the ones who are saving our
country it's not just words you are
saving lives with these vaccines you are
saving lives like the
vice president said it's huge and doing
it the way you guys are doing it also
reinforces
that everybody can trust the system
right
because they look in your eyes and they
can see that you care that you live in
the community that you care about folks
and that really matters that really
matters you're the ones on the ground
making it work thank you for that
we can do whatever we can do in
washington dc but you guys are on the
ground thank you that's why i wanted to
come out today
just landed because i want to hang out
with your governor
and see and see what you guys are doing
on the ground and and to most of all
just thank you guys
[Music]
so keep doing it i don't want to slow
you down though come on
thank you thank you thank you appreciate
it thank you
thank you so much for what you're doing
every one of you thank you vice
president this is
[Music]
and where did you grow i grew up in
washington dc here in las vegas
congratulations what is your specialty
i'm going to be going into
anesthesiology i just found out today i
matched with anesthesiology and my
husband's going to be a radiologist
wow that's heavy stuff yeah you want to
come back here to vegas and work
all right thank you come back to vegas
thank you so much thank you
thank you awesome
hi it's me is one of our csa
nursing students our first year how's it
growing you guys this is amazing she's
been vaccinating but she hasn't been
vaccinated and we said well
we don't have a vaccine between me it's
your first which one are you getting
that's what i have
like the dean of the school of nursing
for csm
college of southern nevada here in las
vegas
and you can see all these people in
light they're all students who have been
helping us we also
hi guys hi everyone
the state we have nursing students from
across town as well as medical students
as well as we've had some paramedic
students
well you guys i'm here on behalf of the
president and myself to just
thank you all for what you're doing you
all are the heroes of this moment and
this is historic in terms of the crisis
but it is also historic
in terms of the heroes who have stepped
up
and you guys are saving lives you are
helping people some who
you may never meet but because they know
what you're doing they're inspired to
trust and believe
in our healthcare professionals and you
all are sacrificing and have been for a
whole year
so much in terms of yourselves your
family
and you keep coming back and so i'm here
to
thank you on behalf of the president
myself and
our country for what you all are doing i
know it takes a lot out of you
we've got light at the end of the tunnel
you've got the most amazing governor we
can imagine
and so um thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
so appreciated thank you all right okay
okay you're ready to shout and
and do you have an idea of what you want
to specialize with uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
on and we're good to
[Applause]
that's right all go thank you guys thank
you thank you for sharing
thank you for just being in some of the
most noble professions in the world
all you do is care for people all you do
is try to make sure people don't feel
pain and that they have a great quality
of life
you guys are the angels walking among us
thank you thank you
thank you thank you a lot of little
halos out here
you're right you're right yeah awesome
thank you so much
thank
okay see you guys later